I've spent the last decade tackling
struggling restaurants you're screwing
the business you can't even cook a
[__] Burger in there ding ding
rounding two but now I'm taking on an
even bigger set of problems I'm checking
in to Hotel
Hell my
God my head is spinning I'm going to be
staying in America's worst hotels so you
don't have
to I'm not sleeping here we're checking
out no way it's bad this is the mattress
cover
[__] me it's like being in Danny
DeVito's house a
shower
help let me out tonight I'll be trying
to bring a haunted hotel back to life
there's a little girl who supposedly
haunts the
hotel [__] the hotel's ex-military owner
I'm the owner I'll say that's how we're
going to do it runs a hotel like a
dictatorship oh you're like a little
[__] Hitler around here damn it he's
wrong can I save a marriage in crisis
and rescue a hotel on the brink of
disaster we're going to make it go or
we're going to shut it up sell the place
sell it cuz this is
madness
[Music]
this is the historic Cambridge Hotel in
Upstate New York it's set in stunning
Countryside a few hours drive from
Manhattan the hotel has 16 bedrooms and
a large restaurant and has had its doors
open for almost 150 years welcome to the
Cambridge
Hotel ex-military man and local lawyer
John imhof persuaded his family to help
him buy the hotel in
2007 I remember sitting in my hot tub
smoking a cigar drinking Bourbon and
life was good and I wanted to take my
wife someplace nice for dinner so I said
to her why don't we buy the Cambridge
Hotel and then we'd have a place to go
he must have hit me at a weak moment
because I said
sure with zero Hospitality experience
between them which one is 827 I don't I
don't know the numbers the hotel
currently falls shockingly short of
guest expectations it's dingy and
there's hair all in through here all
over these pillows be nice if we had a
remote control they're just gobs of hair
we've had remote control since when the'
70s I'm not sleeping here we're checking
out way it's bad when I bought the hotel
I didn't intend to be a Hands-On owner
but I am always at the hotel doing
something one person has to be in charge
got 84 emails 17 from John John is uh
control free
how we doing on that chicken it's
working hard we can do better Chef it's
ready to murder with this menu there's a
lot of restrictions to it our budget's
really tight the creativity is kind of
gone out the window Brit um all the
rooms clean yeah all the rooms coming in
I am currently the general manager X but
John takes away my control I have no
control but General Jon's Hands-On
approach isn't working nobody wants to
stay and the hotel is losing thousands
of dollars every month John wants to put
every penny that that we have into this
hotel and that is something I am no
longer willing to do we are $750,000 in
debt but failure is not an option and I
don't intend to fail at the hotel unless
I can fix things and fast John and Tina
will lose their business and their home
if Gordon Ramsey can't fix us who the
hell else
can wow the real sense of grandeur
definitely some history here Cambridge
Hotel established 1885 home of py mode
I've been Across America I did not
realize it came from
here good morning good morning welcome
to the C Hotel uh Gordon and your first
name s my name is Brittney I'm the
manager I have you in room 117 that is
$105 during the weekday and $135 on the
weekend okay I think Gordon's first
impression of the hotel is going to be
what the [__] are these people doing
the Cambridge Hotel rip seriously yes
it's died you mean no rest in peace is
the ghost that uh live here we are
haunted oh come on there's a little girl
who supposedly haunts the
hotel
Alice Alice
Alice oh my good God she looks like
something out of the easis she was 4
years old in 1913 when she died but I
believe in ghosts at the hotel I
absolutely believe in them going to go
up the stairs they creaky as well and oh
God uh are they the owners no I don't
know who they are those have been here
this place is littered with freaky
pictures what's upstairs there that is
our third floor why is that roped off
because it is not accessible to our
guests is that where the G are well
that's where people say they are if he
goes up on the third floor he is going
to freak out this is your room oh my God
bloody hell look at the
wallpaper what's the post up there what
is that just there so there's no
handcuffs no okay so so it's not a sex
thing it is not a sex thing a really
weird thing to have in the bed I know
so [__] oh
[__] well [__]
welcome to the Cambridge Hotel thank you
Christ Almighty I I am not going to
forget this day in a
hurry horrible linen rough and nasty
holes look at that and the bed doesn't
even fit the base honestly I've seen
better linen inside hospitals
horrible my bedroom is dated and
uncomfortable how could anyone think
this was good enough for paying
customers
bye-bye to meet the owners yes I'll be
right back with the
owners look how dead they
are Gordon this is Tina and John mhof
nice to see you nice to meet you sir
John likewise good to see you both it's
quite amazing when you drive up and you
see this sort of stature of the building
it's yes sir isn't it beautiful it's
stunning until we get
inside Hotel experience prior to this
was what very very little I mean I was
no none none so year One what was the
profit we lost about $350,000 the first
year year two $250,000 profit loss loss
so we're in for
$600,000 within 24 months of business
who's funding this well um my mom and
dad have put in several
$1,000 wow um our children our children
your children yes yes Shay has put about
$25,000 on credit cards Shay is your the
oldest daughter your oldest daughter
right the chef's um significant other
okay and my youngest daughter just lent
us $10,000 your youngest daughter she's
in college was your house on the line
next yes it is up for sale and we would
live here we would move on to the third
floor where' you draw the line and say
stop this is not working you're standing
there like prow coock very confident
very happy and like nothing's gone wrong
but taking money from your daughter that
hasn't even started on the path of her
career I belied that we would be able to
turn it around oh no but John I'm sorry
your parents money your family's money
your daughter's money I I do have a
positive attitude there's a difference
between sounding positive and
sounding full of
crap he doesn't know me and and he
doesn't know the situation I'm a
military guy I'm not going to take Chef
Ramsey's
[__] I've just met the owners of the
struggling Cambridge Hotel and
discovered they've borrowed money from
their kids to stay open I I do have a
positive attitude there's a difference
between sounding positive and
sounding full of crap
unbelievable Tina how do you manage I
don't know how I manage and I was very
close to Running Away several times wow
seriously unreal thank you I've been
frustrated for years with him not
listening to me when somebody doesn't
listen to you for a while you just give
up what is it about John that's driven
his wife and potential guests away I
need to watch the General in action
what are you doing with the Hoover
welcome nice to see you sorry about the
owner walking through with a Hoover are
you joining us for a sleepover or you
joining us for dinner dinner excellent
damn C tell me I help you JN keeps
himself constantly busy but he's busy
doing all the wrong
things his non-stop fussing and
fidgeting is killing the hotel's
atmosphere
doing oh my God
the tables in the bar might be clean but
I've got an eerie feeling the food's
going to be filthy only one way to find
out hello sir how are you good my name
is philli I'll be your
server thank you I'm a little nervous so
am I um what would you recommend well
the soup dour today is a uh vegetarian
lentil vegetarian lentil Y and what was
the soup was your yesterday it was also
the vegetarian oh so super two days H
actually it's longer than 2 days um I'll
go for the pork and beans duck comfy
yeah um pile mode okay okay I think
we're done okay thank you thank you very
much Chef thank you Chef orders up okay
thank you get them going brother get
them going I think that Gordon is going
to love the food chef rich is great we
put out excellent food you
chef wow look at that this is the pork
and bean
holy mael
it it's cold in the middle both of you
yeah just touch that meat there please
cold touch that cold I can see why we'
got rip on the front of the [__]
reception those are two medium rares
right scooters Chuck them in the oven
please Chef ice cold in the
middle tell them it's a soused product
we cook it to order it disappoints me a
little bit that we are
boiling bags putting stuff in the
microwave I wish we could actually cook
with fresher food your duck H feed and
Chef said the pork and beans was a sousi
product and it's cooked to order s oh
cooked in the bag yes they're frozen
frozen yes and this plate that's frozen
I I think that's a subie product as well
do we have anything that is homemade are
the apple pies made here the apple pies
are made here okay can you H it with the
desserts please sure thank thank you so
far everything has been terrible surely
the hotel signature dish is going to be
better how's the apple
pie told them we don't want to complain
anymore I'm sorry but this is the home
of apple pie alot but if it's the home
of Apple P mode it should be really
badass stay away from it it looked like
there was bom on the top of it I'm
bringing it home from my door okay
wow
P mode Gordon so this is it this is the
that is the P mode [__] this plate is
absolutely roasting in the center has it
been microwaved it
has the apples are raw if there's one
thing I was expecting was a decent apple
pie and that is
gross I need to find out who's
responsible for the terrible food here
hello if Chef Ramsey criticizes Chef's
food where is the where is Chef I think
Rich will blow up because Rich does take
things personally I don't know where to
start to be
honest what the [__] is going on well
tell me what what you don't like can you
be a little bit more constructive should
we start from the pork and beans Stone
[__] cold it's a svie product so you
don't even cook that no it's SV no and
can you cook yes so why buy that in uh
price you buy a store bought frozen
piece of pork boiled in a bag and serve
it to me stone cold in the center you're
not even cooking so you're just too lazy
to to do it that's not true I am not
lazy this menu could be run now without
you being here yes it's the way I
designed it this the way you designed it
so you are lazy then I'm not lazy if
Gordon calls me lazy one more time it
could cause a problem might be going
back to Britain in a body
bag I just tasted the food at the
Cambridge Hotel and it was awful I think
it's because the chef is lazy but he's
adamant he's not that menu stinks of
laziness I'm not la I'm here 80 90 hours
a week yeah you can't call yourself an
executive chef come
on do you know it's store board I did
why would you employ a chef that 2/3 of
the menu is store
bought I I think Gordon believes that
I'm incompetent in running a hotel but
what I'm doing is right your hotel
became famous for this apple pie right
and this is the dish that is trying to
stop your house being put up for sale to
keep this place going but I'm just what
I'm trying to say is there are so many
Basics wrong I could [__] cry I could
seriously cry I could cry too and look
at the apples look the apples are raw
not even baked and I could scream when I
see that this this was invented here and
there's thousands of restaurants across
the globe that have copied what you
originated have you any idea how lucky
you are and it resolves to that soggy
undercooked soaking wet piss pie can I
have a quick word with you for two
seconds please I'm struggling to
understand what's going on here I need
toit a woman's perspective John is smart
in what he does as a lawyer mhm he's
awful here I can't get it in his head
but between the two of them they're
about to take your [__] house down
him and John go back and forth when I
give suggestions it's pretty much you
know and then it's pushed aside and then
John it's making decisions you're about
to lose your house I know and he says we
are going until I haven't got another
Penny to put in it he's never run a
business before no no and he's never
done anything in his life but be a
lawyer and a soldier that is it he may
have won lots of battles but he's
[__] definitely losing this war let
me tell you finally a stranger is seeing
what I've been seeing and I'm hoping
that John is going to take something
from this and either we're going to make
it go or we're going to shut it
[Music]
up I've seen about as much as I can
stand at this hotel the outdated rooms
the cheap Linens and the prepackaged
food how have things got this bad I've
got to get some answers what's wrong
with this place and who's to blame
problem is here is that we have to ask
to do something we're not allowed to
make a decision we're not all to make a
de general manager executive chef we
have to run everything through John make
sure everything decision a lawyer so why
don't you have to ask someone that
doesn't know how to run a [__] bath
let alone a hotel but he took over more
control that's when I put up my hands
okay you want to run it you run it it's
[__] soulless it's littered with [__]
antiques that are broken it's got
horrendous pictures all over the [__]
place disgusting rooms food that comes
out of a [__] bag I I don't control
any of that stuff I'm not making
decisions I told Rich that I thought we
should cut our food
cost have you got the
respect from the owners to do your job
properly yes or no no I have AB you talk
I definitely do not make the decisions
that I think I should be able to though
as she's telling you that and that's
what the problem is it's not the [__]
ghost John that's scaring the regulars
away it's you a chef needs to be a
[__] chef and a general manager needs
to General manage I'm not a
micromanager when we first started this
place and the the ideas I had were all
shot shot down that's the kind of stuff
now it's coming out you've handicapped
the chef the general manager is
functional and you're calling all the
[__] shots I'm not call on the shot
you're a Lethal Weapon well you you may
think that no I don't think that I
[__] know that just heard from your
wife your general manager your Chef then
I'm controlling Over Control you're like
a little [__] Hitler around here and
if you don't stop doing what you're
doing you'll lose your family and The
Business
I finally got to the truth at the
Cambridge Hotel you're like a little
[__] Hitler around here the place is
sinking because John the owner's
meddling ways have made everyone's jobs
impossible I'm not a micromanager
they're not
puppets they're your team and if you
don't stop doing what you're doing
you'll lose your family and the
business work it out your honor I'm
going to bed good
night this is all stuff that I've been
trying to get across to John for 20
years what's the matter seriously yeah
what's the matter with you right now you
have a headache again
or I've had
it I have had it I was feeling squashed
and I don't have to feel that way
anymore I'm not going to feel that way
anymore bedtime and I'm not looking
forward to sleeping in a haunted room
I've never seen such a delusional owner
and staff that are so desperate to do
their jobs and now I got to sleep in
this Christ
almighty oh [__] what was
that this bed is so
uncomfy what is that no he on the stairs
Alice
Alice I had a sleepless night and
believe me it wasn't a ghost that kept
me awake it was something far more
frightening time to give John and Tina a
wakeup call after you
please hi
guys these are the guests that have been
staying in the hotel um I've asked them
uh in my room this morning to help you
understand how difficult it has become
for guest actually stay here who would
like to go first I took a shower this
morning and used what I thought was a
clean towel and there was hair in the
towel the B itself was actually very
uncomfortable yeah we left our room last
night and couldn't lock our door so we
had to leave our hotel room door
unlocked hand on Hearts how many of you
would return here no the way
no anyone not unless you pay me to stay
here John and Tina are you aware of so
many problems inside these rooms some of
them we are aware them yeah what I'm
more pissed off about that anything is
that last night I went
downstairs in fact let me show it was
easier if I do it this way I forgot my
toothbrush I went down to the
car and I cannot believe this just watch
carefully I went
outside so stepped down the
stairs all of a sudden damn I've locked
myself out I got no keys to get back
in the bloody front door is not locked
at
night now there's no night Porter
there's no security and then shock
horror I went behind the reception desk
and every one of your keys is hanging
replicated in the pigeon
box wow that's
terrible duplicate key for every room oh
my God credit card details personal cell
numbers it's all
there scary that's scary to think about
why is the door not
locked there's no good reason we haven't
locked in a long time though no about 2
years in this community you have eight
major burglaries with the last 12 months
three registered sex offenders locally
in this community I mean how does that
make you feel that we were sleeping in
this hotel last night and each and every
one of
us was
vulnerable that's not okay irresponsible
thank you thank you guys thank you can I
can you stay here with me and ladies and
gentlemen thank you you thank you
John and Tina have broken the first law
of hospitality keep your guest safe
John's so busy interfering with other
people's jobs he's lost sight of what
really
matters I'm not joking around on the
burglaries the sex offenders I know I
know your reputation could be over in
seconds on one instant in this
hotel because you're not going to walk
around this town as a prosecutor a chief
lawyer and then be responsible for a
serious rape taken in place inside
here wake
up you're running a business not a
courtroom and they're here for an
experience not a [__] sentence sell
the place cuz you're not fit to run it
sell it cuz this is madness sell it and
keep your
house it's not worth
[Music]
it
I've just discovered that John has lost
sight of the big picture at the hotel
the bloody front door is not locked at
night and he's in competence is putting
the guest safety in Jeopardy that's not
okay if Jon doesn't change his
interfering ways he and Tina will lose
their home and be forced to live on the
hotel's top floor it's time to find out
what it's like up there
[Music]
hello anyone there
hello it's like someone oh
[__] bloody
hell who in the hell would put this here
this really is Hotel Hell
oh my God what happed to our
hands this place is genuinely disturbing
freaky that top floor is no place to
live but I've got a plan if I forc John
to see how different things could be
here maybe he'll get the message so I'm
going to need Britney's help if we can
prove to John and Tina if you take
charge and you hold those Reigns that
you can make money this hotel trust me
they back off and you step up mhm okay
yeah absolutely I hear I'm hoping to
prove to John that it can be busy it can
be fun here tonight we are
serving we are doing a bar night oh my
God this is terrible we're not a rowdy
kids doing shots going crazy bar it's a
party party party we're going to do
drink specials we can get people in the
rooms a ladies night two night I have to
pack the place thanks bye this is the
first step to change as last minute
preparations take place in the bar and
the kitchen there's a new energy in the
Hotel this is Chef Richie's chance to
prove he can cook with fresh ingredients
nothing out of a bag please no preheated
all fresh yeah all fresh great Rich it's
your responsibility to teach these guys
how to cook absolutely not to reheat is
that right scoop yeah absolutely he's
just started comary scho oh good man and
who inspired you to be a chef I had
relatives everywhere pushing me to join
The Culinary field because I wasn't
physically able to do any other things
like sports and stuff yeah what's the
disability I've had two heart surgeries
and two back surgeries how old are you
19 yeah you move fast that's a big asset
and you haven't even talked properly yet
have you no that's incredible so what do
you want to be when you grow up um I
would like to have my own Bakery and U
be a professional exz I a patri chef wow
we're right a roll Britney has gotten
the the word out that she's in charge
tonight and people are flocking into the
hotel there you go okay let me ring them
up ladies night is going really well
tonight there's a mixed crowd of Ages
here and everyone hanging out together
and having fun what can I do to help you
nothing get out out
out night's going great but I don't
think John quite understands how
important nights like this are because I
don't think this guy gets the
message
John I want to show you something come
with
[Music]
me that thing Spooks me every time I
come in
here here's the situation downstairs
currently there's a buzz and that got
put together by your general manager
Britney that's her vision but if you
carry on running the Cambridge the way
you have been this is what you're going
to have this is what's your destiny this
on your own so stay up here and sort of
enjoy your
surroundings I'll come and get you when
I'm ready all
right he's so wrong he has no clue and
I'm I'm thinking when he comes back up
he's going to ask me what did I learn
and I'm going to say to him I really
didn't learn
anything plock
damn
it I've locked John the hotel's
interfering owner on the top floor I
need to demonstrate to him how well the
hotel can run without him I'm not happy
sitting there waiting because I know my
guests are downstairs having a party and
I kind of felt that I needed to be
downstairs Gordon wants me to sit up
here and and you know think that he's
all right about all this stuff and damn
it he's wrong about me being a control
freak
with L's night in full swing Chef's
fiance and johnan Tina's daughter Shay
arrives to join in the fun mama I think
she's my last chance of getting through
to John hi Shay hey how are you got one
minute second pleas excuse me thank
you time's running out for you Dad for
your mother and for their house I can't
get through to your father I asked him
to go upstairs and just sit and Ponder
and think that this is is your future
and if you think he's ready to change by
all means bring him down and if he's not
I don't care keep him out of there and
keep him up
there hey Pops hey sh what's going on
I'm just up here
uh sitting down and waiting waiting to
go back
downstairs I think the point um was to
try and visualize what could potentially
be the future oh no I've been doing a
lot of thinking too yeah I've been doing
a lot of thinking I thought my role was
about the same all
along I feel like it's changed a lot and
I think a lot of it
is a fear of
trusting you don't have to be here all
the time when was the last time you sat
down at home and had a dinner with Mom
you know yeah I feel guilty when I'm not
here
do you know what's going on
downstairs no it's awesome there is a
restaurant full of people that are
thoroughly enjoying themselves it's
hopping and it's working without you
yeah yeah I'm I'm getting it okay I mean
I'm um it's going to be tough for me to
back off of the working I think it's
important for you I think it's important
for you and Mom you know you're making
good points Shay I think you would be
able to spend more time with your
granddaughter oh I'd love
that it's
possible you don't want this to be your
future no you don't want to live here no
I don't you have to commit to change
yeah yeah I I I understand if Mom will
put up with me being home
more love you I love you too Shay
I I've it's an epiphany I've I've just
now realized my control is What dra is
dragging the hotel down now I need to
make a change um in order for my
personal life to improve and for my
business to get better good job
thanks tonight has been a real success
seeing Britney in charge and Rich
cooking fresh food gives me real hope
but is John capable of letting go
my goodness it feels weird it's sounding
so quiet now right all well done behind
the bar well done in the kitchen scooter
well done ladies great I mean you could
get a a seat of the bar within 20
minutes that's how it should be how much
do we take under $1,400 in 2 hours
$1,400 in 2 hours we made more than the
last four Wednesdays or four Thursdays
combined John you spent the majority of
the night upstairs say how was your
night it was in a very good night
actually in what way um my daughter Shay
um open my eyes to some things I'm here
every night because I feel that I need
to be here that that is my role as the
owner to wave the flag as a military
term but when it when it came from Shay
as she said you know
Dad I know how hard you work and and I
promised I wasn't going to tear up and
uh this all happened happened without me
you trust your subordinates as a
commander the most important person you
have are your NC's and Chef and Britney
are my ncos I can't tell you how good is
to hear that cuz you a [__] tough nut
to
crack cuz we have got one hell of a day
tomorrow but I need everybody everybody
at their best good
job great
job
what a day I'm hoping that John has
finally got that message but is it all
lawyer crap tomorrow will definitely
find
out oh God
freeing coming up I drag the Cambridge
Hotel into the 21st century and one of
the hotel staff get some shocking
news my design team worked all night to
bring the hotel into the 21st century
now it's time to reveal the new cage
your hotel to the staff good morning
good morning John how are you feeling I
can't wait to see what you've done in
there right you ready to go in yes the
only way we're getting in is with this a
key let's go let's go the door is locked
so your guest can sleep safe and sound
come in unlocks good good right come
upstairs I'm hoping you're going to love
my room I think it's absolutely
gorgeous oh my God look at the floor
wow taking the carpet out and putting
that flooring in absolutely transformed
it the wallpaper was expensive in order
to enhance it we work with it so we got
the back drapes above the bed we have
this amazing new floor yes perfect
furniture that fits the room we've
upgraded every room with brand new linen
and towels
$75,000 worth of linen oh my God my God
we could have never afforded that that
is so wonderful I feel like kind of like
a kid that comes down Christmas morning
and there's so many things under the
tree that you're you're in overload I
can't really comprehend everything yet I
mean I'm just kind of looking at it
saying
wow ready for one more room oh oh my God
I don't know if I can take it wow wow
wow
wow I can't wait to actually show a
guest upstairs to a room I love it I
love it I love it um there's one more
little thing I want to show you
downstairs come with me please in the
1890s the Cambridge Hotel gave birth to
world famous pyer mode and I think that
dish can put the hotel back on the map
today something I thought was a huge
missed opportunity I've been working on
a an amazing very special apple pie
recipe that I'm going to give to you
that you own and it becomes the best
apple pie in America and on the back of
that we've transformed this room through
here to the alamode room come through oh
my God morning everybody how are
we we can sell our own pie that's
homemade that Gordon is giving us his
recipe for oh my God this hotel invented
pyot and the ice cream is made fresh
here the brand new ice cream maker and
it's l sauce cream I can't wait to try
it I know come with me please enjoy the
apple pie nice to see you please come
through beautiful pile lote dig in dig
in come on guys if anybody wants this
you better get on
it oh my God that's awesome the world
famous Cambridge Hotel apple pie
alamode that is the best crust I have
ever had on a pie welcome to the
Cambridge Hotel we now have the best
apple pilea mode in I'd say the world
people are going to be
excited scoot what do you think bud I'm
shocked you're shocked are you happy I
don't know what to say oh mate don't get
upset buddy what's the matter I'm so
happy oh good I'm happy too as well you
know that okay come on buddy seeing how
much he changed the hotel was very
overwhelming I can feel a change I'm a
lot more inspired right now I feel like
I could accomplish anything in the
kitchen I am proud now there's a new
pride in me to
say this is where I
work time to go I never thought I'd say
this but I'm actually quite sad to leave
this place because no longer is Jon in
denial he can now stand back and watch
his team run the Cambridge
properly as I'm getting ready to leave
guests are starting to arrive at the new
hotel hello welcome guys how are you and
the biggest change of all is not the new
Decor it's the fact the guests are
loving it at the
Cambridge this is
beautiful the restaurant is buzzing the
Cambridge burger with the pork belly
guest are enjoying the new homecooked
menu that I put together with Chef
Rich yeah you better save room for the
pie cuz it's totally different tring the
apple pie the hotel's signature dish py
mode is a big hit that ice cream is
worth driving for
fantastic great buzz in there I mean
it's electric and it's the sound of the
new Cambridge Hotel my only hope now is
that they keep it up and keep those
customers excited cuz when it's like
that it's
phenomenal is that
good a I think tonight went incredibly
well that the fact that I could stay and
and sit with Shay and Addison and bunk
it was really really
[Music]
nice wow to see you smiling is
incredible you know that you light this
place up but I don't want you living
here no I'm not I don't want to live
here I do not want you living here I
won't live here okay tell him that I'm
not living here I hear you give him a
hug he deserves
one he hasn't interfered tonight and you
sat down and spent time with your
granddaughter I had a blast yeah my job
is done let me tell you
no longer
rip okay of the Cambridge it has a
bright future long live the Cambridge
right that's absolutely right before
Gordon came I didn't know where to go
anymore with the hotel and getting
Gordon here and having him show us what
the problem was now I can see that the
things can be fixed I will tell you okay
colen Powell says optimism is a force
multip
player I'm optimistic stay optimistic
but don't get too involved okay okay
look after yourselves thank you very
much sir stay together thank you thank
you thank you before I leave this place
there's one more person I want to talk
to want a big man so you got three more
years left at college right about four
okay hear me out okay I want you to keep
in touch with me okay and give you my
email address cuz I want to finance
those next four years in college
personally and help you okay do it for
you and keep that dream alive one day of
owning your bakery and then when your
bakery is open all I want back is a loaf
of bread okay it's pretty unbelievable
that he he's going to be able to finance
my four years of school well done good
job thank you so much well done can't
wait to finish school and pay him off
for that big loaf of bread you have an
amazing Pair of Hands and a lovely smile
don't stop okay got and God help you if
you fail that college thank you you
won't though I know you won't well done
thank you so much when I go to school
I'm going to push myself 200 times
harder I'm going to show G what I can do
and how fast I can do it good night
thank you very thank you very much thank
you much take care thank you well done
thank you good job man awesome job hey
you deserve
it definitely what a weak what a
place and now whenever I see elode I
know it
started tonight on Hotel Hell imagine if
a teenage boy designed a hotel it would
look like a
Ferrari there's a lot of red there'd be
a chocolate pizza on the menu it's like
someone's wiped their ass with my dough
and there'd be hot waitresses with super
short skirts well this is the keing
hotel looks like a nightclub out there
with those ropes it might seem like a
teenager dream but it's actually the
Twisted vision of a grown man and for
the staff who work here I'm I'm at the
end of my room I have my days numbered
here it's a living hell Jesus Christ
call 911
urgently
San Diego California is one of the top
five vacation destinations in the US and
is home to the keing hotel which lies in
the heart of the city's buzzing Gas Lamp
quarter want to say the desk this is
Christ how many be of
service the hotel is the brain chart of
local property developer Eddie Kane
everything about the place is just the
way he likes it the keing was my vision
I was at the Ferrari dealer looking at
cars and it kind of just hit me why not
have the Ferrari of
hotels but this 35 room Boutique Hotel
is far from living up to guest
expectations oh my gosh Eddie pitches
this as the Ferrari of hotels but it
feels like a hospital sterile almost
this is all style and no substance I
feel like it's a jail like I don't want
to take my shoes off ever this is uh not
exactly
luxury Eddie hired a sports car design
company and sank Millions into the
interior design but he spent on things
the hotel really needs let's not use
this machine for the sheets because it
has rust in the back making life a
misery for his guests and his staff I
have zero resources pretty much
everything there is to do here I do it
how glamorous is this it's a hell
operations here to be
honest Eddie's constantly adding ideas
he's seen elsewhere but that's hurting
the hotel and the restaurant I believe
our menu is [__] joke it's like four
pages long which are all favorites of
eddies but we're not feeding a [__]
million different Eddies we're feeding
different
people is
hor at the end of the day I am the owner
right if there's something I want on the
menu Chef's going to do it yeah I think
I piss them
up Edie will come in and say I want a
chicken parm slider on the menu I had
one in New York and I say yes I have
stopped being proud of my
food the hotel is millions of dollars in
debt and struggling to fill the rooms so
I have my work cut out for me if I'm
going to get this place back on track
we're losing a lot of money it's a
nightmare but you should be able to
handle that Eddie knows he's losing
money I just don't think he knows how to
fix it I don't have any hope that things
will get better if anything Works around
here it's because of pure dumb
[Music]
luck there it is the keting wow looks
nice on the outside beautiful
Jesus is that a dog
outside hello how are you good how are
you is that a model dog or is he real no
she's real what's her name smudge smudge
my God she's
ugly looks like a nightclub out there
with those ropes how are we yeah hello
how are you good to see you there's a
lot of
red wow I'm Christos Christos good to
see you what did you do here lifestyle
coners down here at the front desk
advising me for my life or you going to
be you need dinner reservation so you
organize everything anything you need oh
now somebody likes red is that smudged
likes red or no it's both the designer
and the owner wow wow wow enjoy your
stairs St what floor we on we're on the
second floor second floor please perfect
thank
you right here I like to always stop at
the car each floor has a different model
car who's obsessed with the super cars
who is that the owner I ready so right
here this is your
room on yes
it's so empty more like a garage in the
guest room and how much is this a night
$759
$759 wow that's incredibly expensive
what's that thing there that is actually
the jacuzzi tub in the middle of the
lounge it is in the middle of Lounge wow
when they designed the rooms they took
away all the interior walls but without
sounding stupid these are car designers
correct they are car designers now
they're putting jacuzzi in the middle of
sweet last time I checked a living room
was for sitting in not taking a bath
jeez how much do these things cost the
jacuzzi tub itself is about $20,000 you
don't take bath in cars Jesus this is
crazy but who wanted all these specially
designed that is own are that's Eddie
that's Eddie yes this is
crazy oh [__] the sports car inspired
Furniture looks cheap and isn't even
functional it's different than anything
else um different from a nice hotel room
oh I don't know about that um who in
Earth want to sit here and sort of watch
the television and watch the television
close it works
though the sheets how can they're all so
wrinkled when I haven't even slept in
there why is that we do them in house
when you say we what do you mean you
don't do laundry lifestyle means
everything your mouthwash it's like gas
sockets all broken and smashed down
there someone's left their dirty ones
there the plastic plants that's
outrageous $800 oh my gosh Gordon
doesn't like anything about the hotel
damn it
anything else if I have any lifestyle
needs I'll call thank you of
course so far I'm not impressed with a
keating's pretentious and uncomfortable
design but maybe it can redeem itself
with the one thing every luxury hotel
should have impeccable room service I'm
starving on J on the desk this is
Christo how many hi this Gordon what's a
little bit bizarre for me I'm ordering
room service at the front desk is
there's no direct line down to the
kitchen there is no direct line down to
the kitchen the communication between
the Departments isn't really there so we
um take care of everything make sure it
it happens listen I'm starving um I'll
have a tomato soup please and then pizza
and barbecue chicken I'm fascinated to
see the chicken parmesan sliders I'll
have one of those as soon as I can
byebye thank you
bye hello hello how are
you thank you my pleasure w is this how
it's normally served yes in a tiger box
yes you pay $800 a night to stay here
and you got to eat your food out of
boxes and plastic
containers are we short the soup cuz
it's not even half full that's how they
serve it that's how that that much yes
it's one cup it's like a retirement home
is that luxury you think no not at all
what would you rather
do sip that out of a cup of course jeez
we we barely got half a cup um anyway
I'm going to dig in if there's anything
else I can do for you just go ahead and
let us okay
brilliant darling I'm
sorry you can say that now it's finished
thank you my
pleasure a chicken parmesan
slider that's
Dreadful ah [__] me now I know why they
got the boxes it's a takeway puke
box Pizza un appetizing in a box
especially when you're spending $800 a
night this place is obsessed with design
but serves room service in plastic
containers no wonder they can't fill the
rules that is not my idea of lock show
let me tell you that's
embarrassing
[Music]
wow how can this place call itself a
luxury hotel I need to get some answers
from Eddie the keting owner and
Visionary hey how are you he how are you
good to see you this place has been your
baby in many ways and I'm dying to find
out the vision the insight into to why
give us a little talk I bought the
building back in 2000 it was around 6
million did you go to hotel school no
you've never run a business before not a
hotel business now wow so I was actually
at the Ferrari dealer looking at cars
and stuff and it kind of hit me why not
the Ferrari of hotels I'm more concerned
what you were smoking at the time than
what you were
thinking why would you take one of the
most highs speec cars anywhere in the
world world and turn it into a
hotel I don't know where he's coming
from but it does piss me off I designed
the keing to be the perfect hotel for me
not for him where should I start the
floor it's all scuffed and marked when
you have a resin floor it needs to be
updated I mean everything's just marked
to hell it feels cheap um the sheets you
can't call yourself a luxury hotel if
you don't have beautifully pressed
sheets okay what's the idea behind
sitting here so when you have guests you
know we can sit down and talk and but
where's the sofa where's the table
where's the fun do you know what hurt
the most I got soup served in a plastic
Bowl but there's a chicken parmesan
slider that tasted like it was cooked 3
days ago who in the [__] would put a
chicken parmesan slider together there's
things that don't go in sliders and
chicken Palm is one of them that was my
idea but you're laughing as if it's
funny and you think because you own the
place you can put that in a roll and
sell it I don't know what he's talking
about this place is not bad so I think
Gordon's were complete [__] you're
trying to convince me this is your idea
of luxury I don't know what to say when
was the last time you stayed in the
hotel it's been a while you cannot stand
there and tell me that there's nothing
wrong with this place when you don't
even stay in
it you bought a building that was your
dream but it doesn't feel like a dream
experience to a guest nowhere [__]
near
[Music]
it I'm at the keting hotel in San Diego
and I've just met Eddie the owner who
who's completely oblivious to the fact
that his Supercar inspired hotel is
seriously underperforming you're the
owner and you bought a building that was
your dream but it doesn't feel like a
dream experience to a guest nowhere
[__] near
it I desperately want to help you only
if you start identifying the problems
okay could you uh send that young lady
up to clear that dog [__] out of there
please
Jesus trust me Eddie is not used to
honesty like that right now he looks
like a baby that's just had his lollipop
stolen how are you who is this guy first
thing he does he's lays right into me
the room service was terrible welcome to
my world he opened the bed up and the
sheets were all like wrinkled and most
hotels have those giant iron and things
that the sheets go through it there we
don't have that I tell Eddie the
problems that we have but it may be
sometimes you tell people something and
it goes one side to another I was in
shock maybe Gord get him to wake up I
don't even know what to say that was
very
[Music]
embarrassing after my meeting with Eddie
I'm ready to see how this so-called
luxury hotel runs on a normal night hi
there how are you guys are you a uh
luxury lifestyle concer no I am actually
Sandra I'm the GM of the hotel general
manager we haven't met how long you been
here I've been here for 6 years okay wow
so you're here from the beginning mhm
wow wow wow W I got a lot to tell you
you got a lot to tell me yeah I bet she
does because the keing seems to have
more complaints than guest our room is
not very clean there's hair in the
cheets as well we turned down our bed
and there's what appears to be a bunch
of sand sand what do you think of the r
it's like a
brothel you've been in a brothel I
haven't what I heard okay wow I can
confirm it is like a rule is
it
oh cheese plate let me check on that
right now we've been waiting for 45
minutes you know if it's not up in 10
minutes just cancel it cuz we'll go to
dinner okay okay how can they make a
guest wait so long for something that's
not even cooked the system for room
service here is clearly not working
taking the orders at the front desk then
passing them to the kitchen is madness
I've never seen anything like this
before let's go through the kitchen
together okay weirdly the hotel's
restaurant the MC is in a separate
building around the corner can you
believe that they're waiting 45 minutes
for cheese board I can't believe it but
I'm not surprised she looked pretty
pissed huh she did look pretty pissed
they sounded pissed the three times they
called as well wow what is it is it a
cheeseboard yes uh where's the [__]
cheese is that it that is it how much is
that $6.99 I believe you're kidding me I
can guarantee someone's going to
complain about that hello how are you
Gordon how are you my name is Aaron
manager you're the manager nice to see
you nice to meet you g um you're the
manager of the restaurant yes sir that
cheese portion there is barely two
little slithers of cheese they waited 45
minutes for it and it's like no one
gives a [__] oh I definitely do now that
you've told me this is the first time
that I've heard of it why would they
wait 45 minutes for something that's
already I I think the process
unfortunately is a little bit slow here
I think getting up the stairs is a
little bit of a challenge why don't you
take the call in the kitchen oh in the
kitchen itself we can take that call
it's definitely an option but we've
always when you think that's faster I
think as the hotel takes it it's just as
fast as so even though the customers are
unhappy with the weight that they've had
to endure you don't want to do anything
for them I didn't know how long the
customer was waiting until just
now wow okay manager not
me Aaron the restaurant manager isn't
taking any
responsibility if he worked for me he'd
be long gone how [__] weird how' you
rate him out of 10 can we go into
negatives Aaron is the king of excuses
as far as being able to kind of weasel
his way out of things but I'm not in
charge of firing
him how we doing over here guys no
wonder the hotel is half empty they
can't even get the basics like room
service and laundry right maybe Sandra
the GM can tell me what the hell is
going on here right we have a chance to
catch up thank you so all these issues
with the laundry where's the laundry
done let me show you
please oh here we are so this is the
laundry room W bloody hell you have got
your work cut out these are domestic I
know these washing machines are designed
for small families not a 35 bedroom
hotel wow no wonder they struggle
your lifestyle coner come in here
throughout their day to do laundry and
attend the front desk and take room
service orders we all I mean this is
crazy it is insane it is insane I don't
know how we do it sometimes who presses
the sheets we don't we don't have
equipment so you don't press
them can I show you where we are in the
pillowcases absolutely God there
somewhere else you seem to know all
these problems and you're the general
manager but if there's one person who
can stop this it's you if the owner well
yes I can quit I can leave to another
hotel and go where everything is much
better it is hell to run this place
you're a general manager M yet you're
managing nothing I spoke to the owner I
said this has to change what's going on
Gordon is totally right with what he's
saying but is Eddie being so involved in
everything that's the problem I have
conversations with the owner about what
works and what doesn't work in the
restaurant no matter how many times I
say you know what we should not have a
book as a menu Eddie comes up with
whatever he wants but no one's taking
responsibility I pull back my duvet and
the Sheets Were
shocking $800 a night to stay in
something pretty mediocre you should be
ashamed I am ashamed I am ashamed I got
to get out of here let me get down to
the
restaurant
Jesus coming up I've never seen anything
so [__] unappetizing things at the
keting go from bad to worse I wouldn't
serve any of our dishes to my DG you
okay and one of the staff reaches his
Breaking Point call 911 please quickly
[Music]
urgently for a so-called luxury hotel
the keting has been a major
disappointment it's like gas the owner's
misguided Vision you're trying to
convince me this is your idea of luxury
it's taking its toll on the staff it is
hell to run this place hopefully the
food in the hotel's restaurant is better
than it was in my room are you
there table of one
please good evening hey good evening how
are you I'm very well and yourself very
well thank you and sorry to the m my
name is David David so what did you do I
am actually the restaurant manager here
I thought I just met the restaurant
manager the little man I'm the other
restaurant
manager and the food how would you rate
the food out of 10 six six I wouldn't
serve any of our dishes to my dog Chef
Brian's kind of given up so much has
been taken out of Brian's Hands by Eddie
that I don't think that he has the
passion in the drive to be that great
anymore starting off with chicken under
a break what does that actually mean it
means it's drier than a
bone amazing even the manager thinks the
food's terrible here and he's not
embarrassed to tell me and then the
capatti kevi yeah here we go with
chicken Sun Tomatoes mushrooms you like
that one no [__] really uh I'm still
going to try it so for desserts I'll go
for the chocolate pig um it's a 10in uh
dessert pizza chocolate strawberries
bacon how can I resist that thank you
very much indeed thank you the table I'm
ringing right now just bring it as it
comes okay everything's Under
Fire that's for and right what do we
have here this is the brick chicken $21
$21 brick chicken yeah it looks like
someone's just shat a brick
[Applause]
it's so dry yeah I mean really dry
that's actually better than usual really
yeah chicken under a brick is where it
should have stayed because it should
have never come out of the
kitchen wow pardon my reaching okay this
is the kabat tapian chicken
okay Bland chicken's dry way too much
Rosemary and just it's [__]
at least I've saved room for dessert
what you have here is the chocolate
pig white and dark chocolate
strawberries bacon it's like we've had a
crisis with a toilet paper Department
someone's wiped their ass with my
dough I mean it's just I've never seen
anything so [__] unappetizing as a
dessert in all my life
absolutely bacon and chocolate pizza om
FG
see him SP it up yeah he didn't like any
of it not one thing [__]
me is the chef off tonight no he's in
the back he's in the back is he cooking
or no so he's here but he's not
cooking I would uh really like to meet
the uh executive
chef
Chef Brian ruford Gordon Ramsey how are
you let's go somewhere out the line
shall we I'm lost for words I just you
know I don't know I didn't know where to
start I'm why wouldn't you cook for me
why wouldn't you do that it's not a
question of me not cooking for you it's
do you want to see what we're doing here
and improv because I want this to
improve you've been here for how long 5
years 5 years but you've been cooking
for 30 years 33 years 33 years I didn't
see you on the line I didn't see you
taste anything see you I didn't even see
you inspire anybody this position is
killing me in my soul I've just been
doing everything that Eddie wanted we
have two large a menu for the amount of
business we do if I have 120 items on
the menu and we do 50 people a night how
much of this am I able to prep on a
regular basis to have quality but you're
the executive chef on the menu yes I am
how can you let that food go out with
your name above it um you can't just
give up an almost you know Abandoned
Ship before it sunk I'm at the end of my
room you're toast I'm tired but you're
you're you're an experienced
guy you
okay look at me look at me it's stand
you
okay are you on medication yeah excuse
me can you get me some water please
quickly can you get me a chair
please a
chair Jesus Christ call 911 please
quickly 911 Jesus come here Jesus Christ
urgently what happened the chef's on the
floor oh [__] I you okay call 911 Jesus
Christ Chef just fell collaps can I have
some water please and a cold cloth
urgently just trying to stay
alert look at me look at me
Brian can you get me a chair please a
chair Jesus Christ call 911 please
quickly 911 Jes come here Jesus Christ
chef's on the floor Jesus Christ Chef
just fell collapsed just try and stay
alert drink some
water no job is worth this let me tell
[Music]
you I was with the gentleman where we
just standing talking unfortunately he
just claps and banged his head on the
back
a I am really pissed off at Gordon he's
stressing everybody out everyone seems
to be at their boiling point has he been
stressed out for long I mean this put a
lot of stress on all of us and but me
being here yeah but do not dare [__]
go anywhere near that I put him in that
ambulance got it let me tell you
something 150 items on a [__] menu
the size of a [__] shoe box can send
that man to an early grave let me tell
you it's like he's a dead man walking
yeah and what he tried to tell me in a
5-minute conversation is that you've
overburdened him cuz he does whatever
you want you pay salary but you're not
behind that line you have no catering
experience you haven't spent a day in a
kitchen I've never seen anything so
fragmented okay it's like you're a
little magpie a little spoiled [__]
Magpie that's going around picking up
little bits of glitter and running back
and getting your army to expedite it for
you all that matters right now is that
that guy wakes up tomor feeling better
enough is enough for one day yeah thank
you good
night for me the most important thing is
that he's okay but that guy has the
world on his shoulders and tonight
proved
that what a day yesterday the good news
is that Brian's out of hospital and they
said it was dehydration and anxiety so
I'm going to shoot over to his house
keep the cameras outside and hopefully
have a chat with
him how are you sir come on in I'm so
glad to see you you know know that I'm
telling you how are you feeling I'm
feeling well uhhuh we've got immense
troubles at the hotel you cannot
continue driving yourself into the
ground like that Eddie takes advantage
of my good nature do you feel well
enough to come back to the restant today
yeah good let's get you back in there
and trust me this time it's on your
terms not Edie's definitely good to see
you the restaurant is the beating heart
of any good hotel so the keing has no
chance without Chef Brian thankfully
just a couple of hours after I saw him
Brian is back at the hotel after going
to the hospital I believe that Gordon is
totally in my corner saying get back in
there get it you you got this guy than
now it's time to get the whole staff
together to figure out how to get this
hotel back on track thank you all for
meeting me am I happy to see you or what
how are you feeling more importantly I
am feeling very good brilliant welcome
back thank you
yeah let's get everything out on the
table cuz Life's too short to Festa I'm
here to
help and I just want to hear it from you
guys what's wrong with the
keing the resources as the resources I
tell Eddie all the time Eddie I can do
my job your front reception desk should
not be doing laundry let me tell you
that the big concern I have is the room
service how on Earth do we get ourselves
in that mess as a food and beverage
manager yeah tell me why it's going via
the reception it's determined by you
know Eddie oh my God don't give me
that you're not the owner of the place I
tell you what I want and you guys need
to implement
it why is the menu so big because Eddie
comes up with ideas I Eddie sees things
Eddie has a lot of friends that come in
that would like to see more items on the
menu yeah if I go see something I like
for somewhere else I tell you guys to
implement it but you not not a chef he
is and he needs his identity and he
needs his voice I do know Brian doesn't
like to say no to
me you have a general manager you have a
head chef executive chef you have a
front desk man you shouldn't get
involved and I give them ideas you know
cuz I have a vision here and I give them
the ideas no I take criticism
no I cannot work with you if you're like
this we have the key players the there's
one little problem we have and
unfortunately it's it's you at this
point after last night's dramatic turn
of events Jesus Christ the STA of the K
have finally found the courage to
confront Eddie the owner now there's one
question I have to ask tell me who's the
most important person at the keing who
is
it Eddie bran yeah the most important
person at the keing Sandra who is it I I
got to say it's
Eddie I mean I believe it would be Eddie
Eddie
Sandra no
no the most important person at the
keing is the
guest and I think it's all being
forgotten
about and it's more about keeping you
Eddie
happy we have to focus on the
guest I'm here to put this place right
understand
that Eddie and Sandra just come with me
if Eddie won't listen to me and he won't
listen to his staff maybe he'll listen
to the people who could pay the bills
Around Here Eddie up until now this
hotel has always been about you your
dream your vision now it's about the
guest want me to meet some very
important people I'm just really worried
right now I have no idea what Gordon has
in the room hello how are you I see a
guest that have been staying at the
keing over the last 24 to 48 hours oh no
when I see those guests there I want to
run away right now I wanted to give you
a unique opportunity to hear some very
and I mean very valuable feedback I've
also stayed here um and I am frustrated
but I'm here to get this place back on
the map give me a little insights please
what do you think of this luxury
hotel madam what would you I walked into
the room and it smelled horrible there
was rust in the jacuzzi no
water some of the features in the room
were just lower quality like the plastic
looked a little bit cheap and old so
doesn't feel comfortable M please I just
feel like this place was designed kind
of form over function it was just kind
of weird where is one supposed to sit
and eat breakfast in their room my
husband had to stand up this morning to
have his breakfast while I took the only
chair and sat at the desk I'm sorry our
our room service was um we ordered a
couple of the small pizzas and they
essentially look like microwave piz and
then the order was wrong so we called
the correct they eventually you know
brought up what we actually ordered and
then in the morning they charged us for
both wow I'm sorry anybody else there
was some really high-end stuff and then
at the same time there was just simple
amenities that were skipped are you
saying there's better at the same price
out
there yeah Eddie your baby your vision
um on the back of that feedback no
appreciate the
feedback I have one question for you all
who would return here let's do a show of
hands who would come back to the
keying wow not one
person Gordon's comment about it's not
what I want it's what the guests want
wow I'm starting to realize that some of
the things he's saying actually are
true I really apologize and I am looking
forward to having you guys in the future
I can tell you will have a different
experience Eddie and Sandra you know I'm
not trying to embarrass you but this is
for me critical feedback back and it's
only going to get
better the feedback from the customers
was good I'm realizing there's more
issues than I thought we had and just
being here over the past couple days I'm
seeing what they are I think we can
definitely fix them and streamline them
so the place works a lot more
efficiently and all the guests are happy
thank you I appreciate
it Eddie is starting to see how much
things have to change for this place to
succeed but for the hotel to have a
Fighting Chance of turning a profit I've
got to find a way to reignite Chef
Brian's Love of Cooking show the gang
what we can do yeah I don't have much
passion here anymore I'm hoping that
that that Gordon being here will nurse
it back and right first was the roasted
beet and B salad they've just been
seasoned with a little touch of salt
pepper and then finished in a little
hazelnut vinegarette scallops I like
serving scallops with a nice sear so
Touch of salt pepper little bit of
vinegarette I've just made it sort of
citrusy good sorry I love it when you
get excited like that see that energy
coming back I absolutely love it
I just have a little
taste are you okay
Brian you're killing me there's two
things on the plates got the scops and
the onion P when I'm on the line with
Gordon the energy level just pops up and
now I'm you know I'm standing a little
taller and it's exciting nice happy
yeah good so nice to see you smiling you
know that Gordon kind of unlocked the
chains that I had allowed to be put on
I'm with you every step of the way but
you need a voice in here and your voice
is on that plate let it
scream I love Eddie but I have to be
able to just say this is not going to
work this is not to the benefit of the
hotel the guests the restaurant or
anything you can do it and I know you
can do it I needed this
to remember what I used to do and
that that there's no limit to what I can
do in the
future Brian and Eddie are both making
great strides and tonight my design team
will move in and try to get this hotel
out of the pits but first there's
something I've just got to try I've got
a 25 Grand bath so I might as well use
it
that does not fail and sound like a 25
Grand bath let me tell
you someone's been ripped off right tow
please it's been a challenging week at
the keing hotel a place that was all
style and no substance but its owner
Eddie has finally turned a corner good
morning morning morning how are we good
excellent it's time to show him and his
staff how my design team have
transformed the keting into a place
people will actually want to stay okay
good let's be honest the keting is a
hotel with huge potential right yes but
you need to focus your attention and
energy to the guests that are staying
here yeah come with me let me show you
the keying let's go come in
welcome wow come in that is great oh my
God it's all opened
up wow there's no more dominant red read
carefully all those wonderful
configurations of your hands welcome to
the
kitting it's just so beautiful isn't it
it's just such an emotional experience
you all have a hand in helping the guest
feel welcome it's amazing you
disappointed the red is gone no no no
it's a brand new warm inviting entrance
to a hotel a ready to see more yeah nice
nice nice come into my
Suite oh my god wow so much nice oh wow
oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my god wow I am definitely Blown
Away wow wow oh my God welcome to what I
think is a sophisticated comfortable
modern Suite yeah let's start off with
that Jacuzzi if guests would like to
take a bath pull the curtains they have
a choice that's how you embody luxury
the sofas you can sit down you can watch
TV 3 m away from the screen Brian you're
going quiet on me again jeez we thought
we were sleek and cool and now it's
beautiful it feels
welcoming come through the bedroom
please I really like the concept of the
made over Suite now it screams the
guests you get stuck in a perspective
sometimes and you need to take a step
back and have someone you know come in
and show you and I think that's what
Goron has done it's amazing now
something really important I've
organized a free trial period from a
local linen company use it to your
advantage that means the front desk team
doesn't need to waste time doing laundry
you got more time to focus on the
guest and Sandra you are a GM you're not
a laundry assistant well lifestyle
concered we don't have to worry about
laundry so I am happy there's more let's
go right excited yes come through we
have refreshed the menu okay oh my God
breakfast pizza I've worked with Chef
Brian to devise a short new menu that
will play to his strengths First
Impressions visually it's very Briant
the presentation's amazing and the good
news is 2/3 of the menu's gone Chef what
do you think I think that this allows me
to speak to the guest and Aaron I want
you as the food and beverage manager to
take responsibility of room service own
it and no plastic containers I I think
now we have the proper execution the
proper understanding of the menu with
limited smaller items we definitely can
execute it a lot quicker and now I feel
a lot more comfortable and that for me
is great news cuz it means the front
desk is no longer looking after room
service or do laundry they can
concentrate on looking after the guests
yes there's one more change we need to
do you've been wearing a red chef jacket
for far too long you deserve a white one
let me tell you put that on thank you
enjoy it I certainly will I'm feeling
great I'm no longer Eddie's Chef in the
red jacket I'm the chef of the Merc
beastro in white it's not Eddie's
favorite color but it is a proper chef
jacket you perform like one you deserve
it make it yours thank you g well
done this is the kind of energy you want
to see every day so you know what as
long as they're doing their jobs I have
no problem with them saying no to me
anymore big night tonight it's going to
be a packed restaurant you've got to
remember you are all team keting I know
you can do it oh absolutely
absolutely guests are arriving for the
relaunch of the keing hotel hi guys how
are you and the first impressions are
very positive this is really yes you
like it yeah oh this is beautiful at
long last the front desk can focus on
welcoming guests how are you welcome I'm
Cindy pleasure to meet you and the
hotel's new white Lobby is a great
Improvement this all red and before it
looked like a bus station and now it
looks like a hotel it looks much more
inviting at the restaurant Aaron is
finally stepping up follow her right and
taking a new Hands-On approach to room
service go come and not a plastic
container in
sight
Mr Hanks right excellent we got room
service over here for you the simplified
menu has brought Brian back to life I
want the most gorgeous plates in the
world coming up in this window that's
good news for the diners so beautiful
it's very tender it's like I don't even
need this KN this is a joint where you
don't need ketchup cuz it's perfectly
seasoned and for the future of Eddie and
the keting hotel keep it going that's
amazing oh my gosh T it's
perfect if I had one thing to say to
Gordon right now is just
thanks all right ladies and gentlemen
it's our last ticket out I've been
really lost here and you've woken me up
great job new day new day and reminded
me of who I
am this place was all about Eddie's
dream of what a hotel should be like but
he forgot the most important person
the
guest I'm just hoping that Eddie can
trust his staff and let them work as a
team because this is a place I'd love to
come back
to okay right Sandra you are a great
general manager don't stop being one
okay Gordon thank you thank you so much
thank you so much I'm proud to be the
general manager of the Kon Hotel give me
a hug come
on all well done seriously you can do
the food beverage you can handle the
room service easily and my God I mean
you bounce back from the dead let me
tell you literally literally make it
yours oh it hold on and do not change
that jacket okay why it suits you you
know that and let your team run your
business okay I think this experience
with Gordon was life-changing for
everyone here what you did to get the
team back together I mean I'm telling
you no one could have done but this
place is on the road and good luck I
can't wait to come back it's one of
those experiences you'll never
forget good job guys sometimes you have
to trust no no no no
no